god let's break it down baby
[Music]
hey guys it's elizabeth berkeley lauren
and i'm here with my dad
mario lopez that's right we're going to
take a look back at just a couple
of our favorite moments of uh saved by
the bell
and uh you know take a little stroll
down memory lane so let's check it out
i bought a pencil yeah sure preppy so i
remember this shirt i really liked it
but look it it's supposed to be like a
polo shirt that comes to like the middle
of my bicep and it goes past my elbows
it was like my dad's
my god was did you wear more of those oh
by the way
remember that particular shirt watch
what polo shirt goes past your elbows
it's supposed to be like right here like
this t-shirt and what did he
i forgot why you were seeing put like
some look at how long it is it's past my
elbows look at how long it is
it's like if i would open my shirt it
would have been like wings
that's screech's dad hey look at how i
was doing the cabbage patch oh that's
like the cabbage patch right there that
little dance i got a little too crazy
hey oh my god you're breaking it down
dad like do the itch
i had i had the rhythm right there yeah
did you even remember that dustin's dad
was a teacher i just remember when i saw
him that was dustin's dad screech is
down right there real life dad i forgot
about that
i think that hair was very blonde right
there his hair used to be different
colors right there was very built very
uh
very blonde sometimes he had it like
billy idol speaking of blonde this was
the only season that they
let me be closer to my real color i was
blonde here
do you notice that and then suddenly
jessie had brown hair wait what's your
real color
it's it's like honey honey all right
honey
screech she's not your fox wait we're
matching
we're matching because our kind of
matching okay i like the curls on you
right there dud
they were like kind of like there was a
lot of poop
you're like mufasa you're like right
there still rock that you know if i air
dry my hair and flip it over
give it like a spritz of shape or
hairspray
what's wrong with it mrs slater mrs
slater
if i really married you i wouldn't use
your last name
whose last name would you use mine
this chick's crazy you know what jessie
was so ahead of her time
come on was she really was right yes
exactly
i'm home great i'm starved oh me too
what are you fixing for dinner
nothing i'm a guy
jessie's standing up for what's right oh
look at your pants by the way sorry to
get
fashioned in this moment but i think
that was the like stonewashed
cavaricci's
yes with the turquoise um
thermal he's taking a stand see this was
what was always cool about jessie
even as a young age not apologizing for
what she believed in yeah yeah
get out of my face and what if i don't
punk
then i'll just have to make you punk
this is funny okay fun fact right here
tell me
i you know i choreographed this fight
scene right dad
this is my first not maria this was my
stunt coordinating debut
right now and i and i get a lot of props
from guys that they like this little
fight scene
you know because with the pushing and
the punches and then you know what's
what's cool about it is there was a lot
of adrenaline starting to build i
remember and but because you had the
choreography set
yeah it made it look real mark paul did
a good job with the little punch coming
up watch i
i probably pushed him in that locker a
little too hard i took that punch like a
pill wait hold on there's not a mat down
there
that was like a hard surface i know i
know i i felt bad but you know we wanted
to make it real
we got all method that looked good that
looked good and then belding for some
reason was dressed up
like held the bar came and broke it up i
don't know why halloween episode
you know what how we can usually tell
the sign on
the hallway yeah you will say like what
holiday it was
this is good wow props props
that wasn't even wardrobe that was like
from my crib i brought that day
just to you not kidding i'm kidding wait
why did i do that i don't know why i'm
doing the ballet i was trying to impress
you of some sort right i didn't know i
did so many
crazy little dances i don't remember the
storyline but what was also genius is
that
just a few years ago you replicated that
on fallon
oh that's right and i wore the same
nailed it and it looked like it was like
pulled out from that era you know what i
mean i remember the audience
a lot of people don't realize we
actually it wasn't a laugh track we
actually had a studio audience so it was
like a pep rally every friday night you
know
that's funny that was a crazy clip yeah
she needs a kiss from dork number eight
it's true the prince is just a friend
but studly for me
is the living end
[Applause]
you are miss dudley and not the prince
now that we've kissed are you convinced
uh
uh well at first i didn't like all of
this drama but
now i trust you so kiss me mama this was
like a hip hop
uh no white version damn i'm looking
like run dmc
we were we rapping even get to kiss that
much
i think we have one more coming up there
it is
my rhymes are on point spitting fire and
uh poor screech is off beat the whole
time
sample that apple you're rapping about
dang that was silly we did some crazy
stuff well i hope you uh enjoyed taking
uh
that little look back at some moments of
uh saved by the bell
um and we're really looking forward and
are excited to
come back july 15th on peacock so we
hope you'll join us and
check it out stay tuned for the new save
by the bell coming soon
you